Are we going to do here?
As soon as you name make you feel smile
giving you
pain is so big that you feel it.
Working Class,
working class,
they heard you were homemade.
Clever,
so fucking crazy.
You can't
be
working class
now.
They expect you
can't even function.
They
keep you dope.
Just so clever and fastness and
how fucking,
but first you must add a smile.
New Loan.
Working Class,
working class.
You don't file.
Hmm?
Come from.
Yeah.
Somebody actually from your crew.
Uh,
peoples and my people was on my Twitter,
I think requested that last time.
I said,
that's not a bad idea.
Shot gun
cause
to me,
you take his last breath,
you come get,
you feel the swim as soon with the
gift that shoot fucking get down.
Get down the speed out your seed.
Everybody jumping around.